él y polán él es analista político
internacional señor von ahn muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
como decía y cómo está trascendiendo
aparentemente estaría ganando una vez
más el unionismo a qué atribuye usted
esta tendencia en nueva caledonia muy
buenos días sí sería bueno que todos
seamos todo cada dedo nos es decir que
todo el mundo y vamos a votar justamente
la otra vez teníamos 81 por ciento de
votantes es decir que es enorme frente a
otras elecciones entonces vemos que
cuando la gente está movilizado aquí
tenemos un bipolarismo entre dos
comunidades étnicas y esa es horrible
hablar de esto pero es tal cual yo tengo
muchos amigos cercanas y el tema aquí es
justamente hay un resentimiento de
cierta parte de la población por el
conocidísimo francés entonces este pico
ahora mismo está haciendo que la gente
se motive para votar las últimas
elecciones que hubo hace dos años
veíamos que no ganó de muy poco usted si
esta vez la comunidad de los los
llanistas van a desplazarse además con
el efecto de lo coronavirus muchos están
las listas no están en francia
es más fácil van poder acceder a las
oficinas de votación y obviamente los
que quieren la independencia también
vale se movilizaron muchos jóvenes se
están votando entonces hay una multi
movilización bastante fuerte de los dos
equipos y sabiendo que es una adicción
no intermediaria pero es una elección
cómo se llama
puntual porque vamos a tener otra en el
si ganar no en el 2022 o sea que va a
ser tres selecciones que se acordamos
desde los acuerdos de mariño exactamente
ahora se trata de un sitio lejano pero
bien estratégico verdad para francia
porque en qué radica esa estrategia
bueno dos cosas si nosotros perdemos
como francés nueva caledonia perdemos
nuestro segundo puesto en el mar o sea
que aquí con las mías no chicas es decir
que es un punto entre australia y nueva
zelandia bastante importante a niveles
geoestratégico era muy importante
también a nivel económico porque habían
iker todavía ni que todavía del 25 por
ciento de níquel mundial pero a los
precios a nivel mundial han bajado
bastante o sea que también ha
movilización otra vez ellos crea una
independencia
entender justamente sustancia económica
ahora va a ser más difícil entonces yo
creo que él no va a estar ganando mucho
más fuerte esta vez